how's it going bros my name is peter pan
i search deep in the codes for a new
unlock and i found there is the pokeyman
mode in five nights at freddy's 3 and
I'm like should probably check that out
so let's do it I'm a little scared
because I have I have a thing if for
Pikachu
if Pikachu arrives I will be so scared
my god I'm scared Pikachu Pikachu
pick a peak maybe you can say you don't
make items
so far no pokemons can be found but that
does not mean we're safe Pikachu he said
are you doing this I think I heard
something
Oh God
what an amazing Pokemon back at you oh
my god it's way scarier in Pokemon
edition the births have no idea oh god
what was that
well Pokemon was said gotta gotta spook
them all okay [ __ ]
ah oh there yeah I was intense
alright so apparently every time you die
it changes mode so now it's five nights
of frozen I don't know what that means
but I am sad and sour you there no I
don't want to be able to sell man please
five nights where you speak achoo
I mean where's Elsa where's Elsa dammit
i reboot at all I'm so stupid
Oh God
I hear the vents
I don't wanna realize though man
uh what it changed again how is it
possible five nights of bronies what
anything but the bronies Oh God
it all makes sense all the furry
animatronics this this makes perfect
sense for the gameplay where are the
ponies I know they're here somewhere
thinking they're smelling me aren't they
can horses smell ed guys shut up I'm
pretty sure they can I'm sorry horses
I'm sorry bronies I didn't mean to eat
you I didn't know you were gonna be in
the meatballs I love you I don't I hate
horses you can't trust them you can't
trust horses you go behind them and they
kick you that's all that's all I got on
horses plus they taste delicious oh no
damn it
the Brodie's heard me that was a brony
damn it I knew but I knew Balloon Boy
wears a brony
oh god ventilation error [ __ ] they're
everywhere
can't [ __ ] [ __ ] horses I will now
God what happened
stop don't worry about
turn off your [ __ ] hand I win [ __ ]
alright Jesus
[Applause]
my god why is he breathing like a [ __ ]
it's just ponies what are they gonna do
oh god they're in the vents I repeat
they're in the vents
we're gonna have to okay [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah dammit
all right it says this is the final one
it says five nights at Pier to Pyke what
that doesn't make any sense how can I be
in man yeah oh God
ed Gary say you know thank you buddy yo
don't laugh at me again damn you and go
I will not let you eat my ass yep
you better not I move
let's try come back here Edgar where is
he oh no where'd he go where'd you go
I made cysts oh my god don't I get don't
touch me
don't you dare touch me no no now I'm
playing finite support pike it's the
best game I ever played oh my god oh god
I'm so [ __ ]
don't worry about it just kidding oh my
god
surprisingly I wasn't in the game that's
kind of weird
oh there it is well that was pretty dumb
like all my videos awesome high-priced
you like this video I don't know what to
tell you man just just do whatever you
want I don't really know anymore but
thank you for watching and I'll see you
in the next video as always stay awesome
bros
[Music]